[Music]
and you said anything news all the time
submitted by playing a game yeah that
saw isn't it mm-hmm
a girl who was told she can buy anything
with her admirers credit card made a
bizarre purchase what would you do with
a llama uh what would you not do with
the llama you're [ __ ] deprived dude no
one else for John has been stitched up
she gave me a couple free [ __ ] why
is it embarrassed to talk about wife
duties duty
why do you always take his [ __ ] side
I'm not I'm just trying to like wonder
why we can't talk about I'll get the
best [ __ ]
anyway so we did this what did this lady
bug all right so this 17 year old
tweeted this out wait so that's her
lover lover gave her a credit card at 17
so she tweeted this out you're all
invited to my bouncy castle party funded
by the guy that sent me his credit card
after I said no to a date what and then
here are the photos so do like to wanna
dumbass feel like this is something Gina
would do yeah
so she she said no but she got a reward
for saying no because it made I don't
know for some reason I thought she got
the you know it was just her boyfriend
that said hey honey do whatever you want
and then she just did a crazy gift so
this makes it even weirder I mean yeah
but I mean that's kind of weird that
this dude I give this girl his credit
card info like he could have just where
are those guys at maybe it's not his
card maybe he stole it from somewhere
this is dad's card
yeah but credit card for you know post
meets all the time that is a [ __ ]
joint card she's always taking my money
I'd like to pay our [ __ ] pills and I
put 50% down for it too so the technical
just say Bart will read the guy and I'll
read I want you to have something just
in case you ever need anything anything
at all
hold up is that how you raise your baby
boy but did it skip I think it skip
something
Oh anything your heart desires and then
how about if she said a [ __ ] diamond
and Crescent Rolex watch everything okay
and then he sent a screenshot of his
email saying jumble of jumps and it's
like a confirmation of welcome to jungle
jumps thank you for creating an account
hey what is this you said anything right
did you just buy a [ __ ] bouncy house
[Laughter]
email of the order and then you know
like when I was a kid I thought only
rich kids had those yeah I never got
about my friends I had one of those I'm
my [ __ ] god damn you guys didn't have a
bouncy house for your birthday
no you're Mexican I thought that was
like a prerequisite for birthdays I
don't think those were really pop were
they really pop yeah yeah but your
brother hasn't for every single party
your brother knows how to give it back
to the kids maybe cuz he didn't get one
so he was like when I'm an adult
really popular no I can't popular [ __ ]
did you get one for Isaac you got to get
what Isaac yeah you got to give him a
traditional Mexican birthday
that's that traditional you would never
have a birthday party no matter whose
birthday it is gonna happen
that's not a traditional he's been
around since I was a kid I'm not saying
the bounce house I'm saying the fact
that we always have the Mexicans always
have it now and it's always in the front
yard thank you you got a flex I usually
love going into those houses because I
like doing like the flips like jumping
up oh yeah me myself in the face and I
was like it's not worth it but then I
try again I was like going into those
houses with smaller kids because you get
the body slam or you jump really hard
next to them I was always that kid that
you would jump next to and then one time
I was at this party and then a kid did
that and then he ended up landing on my
eye my whole open eye was swollen and
red and I was scared that I was gonna be
like surgically removed and I was gonna
be playing why'd you try to sabotage him
for what I saw his foot coming down no I
mean uh - they'd be pushing like this
and then they came over and they pushed
me hard and I was like yeah and then he
[ __ ] stomped on my face
how old was I I think I was like 7 Thank
You me I'm very sure Elmo Casa yeah a
little so little booger yeah yeah like
snot-nosed Oh
moco sigh I just googled the history of
inflatable structures and it was
designed in 1959 if you guys are curious
been around for a while in Louisiana
I thought the Mayans invented it and
it's been a Mexican tradition ever since
oh they used to make it out of corn husk
leaves yeah
blow everything yeah Oh in Mexico with
that buffalos yep Oh crazy yeah but what
would you guys buy if you were in this
gross I'm [ __ ] llama well the ones
that have the [ __ ] hair can you ride
llamas
probably can why not that'd be pretty
sick yeah why not yeah Michael Jackson
had a llama arrival I don't know I
didn't research you write anything right
I mean you'd always be you know if you
write a dog it's like an arrest
giraffes but when I was writing can you
ride the next one was a zebra can you
ride it again oh yeah you can back in
the day the Incas used llamas as messy
yeah felt it in my heart like you
already connected the truck through the
egg their ancestors are still doing the
same today
people always want to know if they can
ride a llama I've heard that some llamas
have been trained to carry small
children what actually luggage carriers
and not for people
hmm people are so lazy what else would
you guys buy oh man it's like there's no
limit on the credit card and I get to
keep it
I think I would just buy a whole bunch
of clothes really it would be my first
like I'm so not like imagine it
yeah I buy a yacht oh [ __ ] and I just
move into the yacht and just lived it up
in my house I think my change money
it's not big enough no cuz this is all
real took mansion on it okay you got a
top bar my shits all stupid the [ __ ]
lava beyond the budget - you can teach
me allow me to get hops and jump onto
the yacht it's waving back because it's
the credit card competition and it's all
like all all ten contestants spend yeah
but we're a [ __ ] couple what's - come
on but during the show you know that
producers are gonna gotta create some
drama so you're gonna wave your wife I
don't know okay well if the card had no
limit the night be way more creative
it's like a 18 year old you guys are
gonna get in trouble when a genie comes
to you because there's always some time
imprint yeah so what do you got to do
yeah yeah for the more expensive to give
the more you have to give but in this
scenario no that's my doctor you just
deal from him about the docking taxes
yeah they might even guy 10 G's a month
or something what about a llama
oh yeah it's like those uh you know when
people get those free cars and [ __ ] but
the bra and all have to like pay way
more out-of-pocket and they go into like
mad dead no later regretted taxes a la a
lot cuz people can't even afford it in
the first place yeah so they can't pay
the tax they can't pay the gas on it
they can't pay so they just got a car
that's sitting there that's making them
drain and like I feel like the
registration you get a car you get a car
you go into the is she like in trouble
or anything like that for him well
that's where the story ends honestly how
much is a bouncy house it's like 300
bucks
wait no 300 they bye-bye for 300 bucks
no what
away an inflatable mattress to the other
day yes no it's not big five yeah I'm
just going for like 50 bucks $49.99
comenzar legit 300 sounds a lot oh well
the ones that they have those aren't
even real these hi I'm talking about the
real [ __ ] Rika bodies and I'm a
five-year-old it won't get hurt I think
you need to get a quote it's got to be
made from like tent material like
parachute material eleven thousand I
wouldn't even rent one for three hundred
gonna scout no it's to buy though you
need like a generator you know oh oh
yeah with a pump in all that cheese my
mom bought one for my brother's like a
generator I know a bounty Oh weird get
no balance a bounce house but it wasn't
like the legit kind night we weren't it
was kind of like a Walmart version of oh
don't work it was so pretty dope they
got everything huh every down so what
look at you now oh I get jealous - yeah
what would you get if you had credit
card I would probably want to travel so
I'll probably buy an airplane ticket
that's to be a one-time purchase though
cuz that guy might ask for it back like
you guys ship back or if you want to do
that just buy something big and then you
can use your points yeah wait those are
on his credit card sell it later
mmm-hmm I could I don't know I was just
thinking yeah probably just buy a Boleyn
then you could travel anywhere you want
to go yeah but they have to think about
the pilot and then this card has zero
limit like you're following those cards
like that out there all right let's be
realistic
he's probably 17 - and if you're not a
rich kid then there's a limit $500 now
now try to do that dream small
yeah dream small I love that shirt shirt
dream small dream small realistic it's a
crop might don't work can you get a
llama for 500 bucks
go check below cuz you can't even buy a
purebred dog but maybe you can't cuz I
feel like you get goats for cheaper it's
maybe in Mexico like 1,500 to 2,000 okay
I can buy a lot what about a non
purebred llama like maybe you could get
it at the exotic animal pound yeah I
know see like what I'm in it yeah we
have to dream small it's hard to be
creative fine I'm getting a raccoon a
raccoon what he can do with a raccoon
bro if you get it from a baby I think
you're thinking too she follows a lot of
raccoon eye jeez yeah yeah
this [ __ ] recognize like a million do
this [ __ ] they're like eating wait did
you did you see the raccoon I'd dip
cotton candy in the water disappears
yeah because like rock Cruz he liked to
like dip their food and water to go it
kind of clean it before they eat it and
so this raccoon got like cotton cotton
candy and visit in there and they're
like dipping and he's like where'd it go
so this girl's going camping and she
gives she's trying to feed him a
marshmallow and the [ __ ] rock who
takes the whole bag out of her hands the
[ __ ]
hey guys thanks for watching that last
episode did you love it I know you did
but guess what you can also follow us on
our personal social media accounts with
the links in the description box below
so go follow all of us now to watch more
videos check them out there
[Music]